rossi what's our next story well for
anyone out there dating but feeling just
a little bit stuck could it be that
you're ground hogging let me explain
stylist reports that groundhogging is
when you are stuck in a cycle of dating
the same type of person over and over
and we know we've all been there and it
just ends up disappointing a lot of
people say they have a type based on
like a physical appearance or something
or career path but according to the
dating app inner circle four out of five
people say dating their type is not
working for them girl wake up it's not
working so if this sounds like you
experts say it's time to start thinking
out of that box right surprise yourself
try a date with someone who doesn't
match your usual type or your criteria
just to see how it goes i love this idea
we love this what do you have to lose if
you try something exactly thank you
isn't the definition
of insanity doing the same thing over
and over again expecting a different
result have you ever found yourself sort
of dating the same type of person and
getting the same result
when i was younger absolutely yeah i
think i was the groundhog too like i was
stuck in the same pattern you know i
just was like
fun sexy let's drink let's party let's
travel let's play like you know it was
more hedonistic less sustainable oh
uh-huh
i'm glad i did it because you know now
i'm so sustainable
yeah
i'm less hedonistic totally
the tables turn i don't think we
necessarily groundhog in our own life i
love when people
like know that they're capable of change
and people are capable of change so
anybody who wants to turn a cycle or
break a pattern you can absolutely you
can absolutely i've seen the evidence of
it with my own
behaviors um i've seen it in other
people so if you are ground hogging and
you would like to
break that cycle it's all up to you you
can um but i love saying that you're
groundhogging if you are sort of doing
the same thing over and over again it
makes so much sense
and i love the suggestion of going
outside
your typical
um
person that you're drawn to or type
i always also find it shocking when
women are like he's too short i'm like
who cares
does it what's his fico score girl let's
talk you know what i mean
who cares about him
short not a guy any day of the week
don't cry
no absolutely yeah if you're
groundhogging you better stop her or the
only thing you're going to see is your
shadow by yourself
[Applause]
so switch it up absolutely well before
we go a friendly reminder that now you
can take us on the go with the drew
burma show podcast
you can listen to the whole show every
weekday just look for us wherever you
pod and we'll be right back
[Music]
you